[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous lors du 7-8 journal sur
tv 60 18 26 minutes pour faire le tour
de l'actualité locale et régionale tout
de suite les titres de ce mercredi 27
juin les soldes d'été ont débuté
aujourd'hui dès 8 heures ce matin le
centre commercial one nation paris aux
clayes sous bois accueillait ses
premiers clients une période pour faire
de bonnes affaires mais aussi de
vigilance pour les consommateurs nous
recevons philippe le rêve président du
ufc que choisir est région versailles
c'est la langue internationale l'anglais
est incontournable dans beaucoup de
milieux professionnels à montigny le
bretonneux mini-schools propose de
débuter l'apprentissage des trois ans et
des initiations qui se passe par le jeu
vous le verrez dans cette édition
et puis ce sera une sorte de répétition
générale avant la ryder cup et chesnay
open de france débute demain au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
40000 spectateurs devraient venir sur
place pour voir notamment le numéro deux
mondial l'américain justin thomas et
nous recevons également dans cette
édition pierre colas chargé de
communication à la maison est triolet à
wagon nous parlerons de l'été au site
situé à saint quentin en il a faim à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines ah pardon
avant de développer c'est rites ses
titres une bonne nouvelle pour votre
portefeuille après de hausse de suite le
prix du pass navigo n'évoluera pas cette
année est la présidente de la région
valérie pécresse l'a confirmé dans un
entretien accordé à nos confrères de 20
minutes elle son prix mensuel restera
donc à 75 euros 20 une nouvelle
augmentation aurait été mal perçue par
les franciliens en cette période de
grève a justifié valérie pécresse est la
grève perlée à la sncf qui prend fin
d'ailleurs demain après trois mois deux
mouvements unitaires pour cette dernière
journée de perturbations et les
prévisions restent les mêmes à saint
quentin en yvelines un trafic réduit de
moitié
un train sur deux annoncé encore pour le
rer c ainsi que les ailes ligne n ai eu
du transilien retrouver tous les
horaires sur transilien.com
et sud rail ainsi que la cgt cheminots
appellent déjà deux nouvelles journées
de grève pour les 6 et 7 juillet au
moment des départs en vacances est les
français dépensent en moyenne 200 euros
pendant cette période c'est le top
départ des soldes étaient elles vont
durer six semaines jusqu'au 7 août
et depuis ce matin les commerçants
accueille les visiteurs venus profiter
de réductions aux clayes-sous-bois one
nation paris a ouvert ses portes à 8h ce
matin deux heures avant l'heure
habituelle avec camille lambert était
sur place
à peine arrivé et déjà les premiers
achats jamel est un habitué de cette
enseigne
il est venu dès 8 heures pour profiter
des réductions j'ai pris quelques
articles j'ai pas de budget spécialement
dans le jeu vieilli six jeux j'ai choisi
je regarde ce qui me plaît puis voilà
pour ce magasin les deux premières
semaines de soldes représentent 30% du
chiffre d'affaires de la saison
un rendez vous immanquable pour lequel
les responsables se prépare on a une
préparation assez dense déjà depuis la
semaine dernière on a aussi augmenté
énormément les équipes on a quasiment
doublé le staff sur la première semaine
parce que c'est là que tout se joue
turin mercredi normal on est 4 et là on
est
8 ce week-end on sera onze ses seules
deux sont les dernières à durer six
semaines dès l'an prochain elles seront
à quatre semaines a one nation paris
toutes les boutiques sont prêtes
le centre commercial outlet a ouvert ses
portes deux heures plus tôt pour
accueillir les visiteurs suis venu hier
soir et puis j'ai essayé ce que je
voulais prendre et voilà je suis
militant qui a pas trop de monde pour
essayer de faire les achats rapidement
si je tombe sur quelque chose qui me
plaît
sinon j'attends toujours les milieux des
seuls d'un général les cinq premiers
jours de soldes c'est 30 % de trafic et
chiffres de la période des soldes d'été
je sais que le budget est un petit peu
moins fort en été parce que les pièces
sont un petit peu plus fini il ya pas
les manteaux etc
mais on est sur des tickets 250 350
euros un panier au dessus de la moyenne
nationale en 2017 les consommateurs
avaient dépensé 200 euros ils ont
jusqu'au 7 août pour finaliser leur
achat pour l'été one nation paris
propose également de nombreuses
activités sur ce sujet des soldes
justement avec nous en plateau philippe
fleuret bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes le
président du ufc que choisir région de
versailles l'association de défense des
consommateurs
alors les consommateurs qui peuvent
profiter pour pendant cette période de
soldes de bonnes affaires c'est aussi
une période philippe le ray où des
risques existent oui toujours
c'est à dire avec des défauts ce solde
ou des prix qui ne correspondent pas
forcément
au pourcentage annoncé par rapport au
prix de référence oui est ce que cette
période de soldes d'été pour les
bénévoles l'ufc que choisir et une
période de vigilance particulière pour
une vigilance ceci dit il y assez peu de
de réclamations ou de litige qui
reviennent vers nous s'il ya vraiment
des litiges de la fraude d'affaires des
commerçants ça va du côté de dgcrf de la
préfecture bouquet alors c'est une
période qui va durer six semaines c'est
d'ailleurs la dernière année sous cette
formule puisque le gouvernement va
baisser cette durée à quatre semaines
pour l'an prochain en tant qu
association de défense de consommateurs
est ce que cette réforme est bien perçue
pour les consommateurs oui parce que je
dirais que les soldes l eau perdu un peu
de leur importance pour les peaux les
consommateurs c'est à dire que tout au
long de l'année il y à des promotions
des différentes offres de réduction et
donc laisser des soldes ne sont plus un
moment privilégié même si c'est très
important même si importants mais on
voit régulièrement tout au long des
années une baisse comme 1 du montant des
ventes au niveau des soldes qui n'est
plus privilégiés vous le dis d'autant
plus que la période n'est pas forcément
propice
il ya des grèves en ce moment là dix ans
au début de ce journal la météo qui a
qui est clémente maintenant mais qu'il
n'a pas forcément été il ya encore
quelques semaines
oui alors finalement ça devrait voir une
conséquence favorable pour les
consommateurs c'est à dire que les
soldes devraient avoir parlons à 30 ou
40 % à peu près en moyenne de réduction
on peut penser qu'il re jusqu'à 60
peut-être 110 % de réduction dans
l'habillement par exemple on disait six
semaines de soldes ça sera bientôt
quatre semaines
c'est l'occasion de rappeler que cette
période des soldes est définie par la
loi
oui c'est défini par la loi c'est très
encadré et c'est repris d'ailleurs dans
la loi un pacte qui est à en propane et
de l'assemblée nationale pour faire un
point sur du côté des commerçants
quels produits peuvent être soldés et
finalement à quelles règles doivent-ils
ce qu'on se conformer alors c'est
essentiellement les produits de
l'habillement ou l'électroménager par
exemple
donc les produits d'avoir été mis en
vente au moins un mois avant
ces randos page commence à ne pas
acheter des produits spécialement pour
mettre en scène ce sont des invendus et
donc les produits doivent être
clairement affichée l'ancien prix le
nouveau prix est donc le pourcentage de
réduction et comptait consommateurs quel
réflexe
doit-on adopter quand on se rend
justement dans un magasin pour les côtés
consommateurs ce qui est important c'est
de repérer avant de repérer avant
l'ouverture des soldes les articles qui
peuvent intéresser des consommateurs et
puis donc après le jour de soldes bien
remarque bien regarder si la réduction
est fait
voilà je peux parler d'internet aussi à
presque ya beaucoup de soit 2,6 sur
internet alors là c'est plus difficile
pour le consommateur de s'y retrouver
l'important c'est d'aller sur des
comparateurs par exemple de regarder le
même le produit sur différents sites
pour voir si loin pour voir le
comparatif alors en termes de droits de
consommateurs sur les articles soldés ce
que comme un article normal et ce qu'ils
peuvent être repris et changer alors
voilà donc il existe comme pour les
ventes normales le
le droit de rétractation et puis alors
alors le commerçant lui a la possibilité
de dire nous ni repris ni remboursé 1
ceci dit dans la pratique la plupart des
commerçants soient accepte de les
changes ou bien font rien à voir donc
aux clients il est important de demander
lorsque le client achète de demander est
ce que je pourrais avoir de problème une
reprise ou alors vous parliez de litiges
tout à l'heure c'est ça va nous
permettre d'élargir pour cette fin
d'interview l'une des missions justement
du ufc que choisir c'est de recueillir
les litiges et aussi d'aider les
consommateurs dans leurs démarches
oui tout à fait pour votre information
dans passé nous avons traité dans
seulement pour la région dur side plus
de 700 litige et nous avons récupéré
trois cent cinquante mille euros qui ont
été reversés intégralement au
consommateur donc même des sommes très
importantes et sur quels domaines
intervient l'association tous tous les
domaines de la consommation que ce soit
tous les achats de biens de consommation
le secteur de l'assurance de la ligne de
l'énergie de l'immobilier tout les
secteurs de la consommation sans
exception vous disiez 7 sont ni tiff
sait combien de bénévoles qui sont
mobilisés l'associé de bénévoles au sein
d'associations mais pour le traitement
des litiges nôtre vient aussi également
avec des juristes stagiaires déjà qu'ils
sont en master 2 que nous recrutons et
qui font leur stage tant que
professionnel au sein de l'association
tous les domaines de la consommation
sont sont traités là les dossiers
actuels en ce moment pour vos bénévoles
de laquelle son approche des vacances
donc il ya toujours des problèmes de
transport de train d'avion genre de
choses et notamment alors c'est pas
forcément l'antenne locale qui gère ça
mais il ya un guide qui est élaboré
chaque année au moment des départs en
vacances parce que les vacances aussi
une période à pied il ya des pièges à et
lui ai conseillé par exemple des
locations qui correspondent pas
ce qui était sur la photo où elle n'a
pas la présente annonce voilà mais
également au sida parmi d autres actions
que nous produisons actuellement il ya
une action importante sur l'eau le prix
de l'eau qu'on peut retrouver sur le
site donc de laisser que choisir c'est
que choisir pour un point org qui fait
qu tacot part d'yves delot sur toutes
les communes de france donc ça c'est
très important et on produisait
également une opération stop pub pour
éviter la publicité dans les boîtes aux
lettres également des publications vous
est d'ailleurs venu avec l'une de ses
filles
voilà que choisir merci philippe fleuret
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes le président du ufc que
choisir région de versailles
et pour plus d'informations et contact
et les bénévoles du ufc que choisir vous
pouvez vous rendre sur le site internet
qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
il n'y a pas d'âge pour apprendre une
nouvelle langue selon plusieurs études
le plus tôt et même le mieux chez mini
school à montigny le bretonneux les
enfants dès 3 ans sont invités à
travailler mais surtout à s'amuser dans
la langue de shakespeare camille lambert
et nicolas landresse adjoint les desmans
au charme et yes we tu vois les bébés
yes allard hectares mais ici pas
d'exercice contraignant ni de grandes
conversations pour apprendre l'anglais
tout passe par le jeu et les activités
de groupes
après un échec mini-schools ses enfants
connaissent déjà quelques mois
ces dames la lionne et les fonds
manquent ni mr blue wing oasis kamana
âgés de 5 à 7 en lan à alaric et youssef
retrouve clémence chaque semaine pendant
une heure animatrice au sein de
l'association elle s'appuie sur des
visuels des comptines ou des objets
colorés pour enrichir leur vocabulaire
mini schools ils ont une façon de faire
qui est assez particulière c'est à dire
qu'ils partent du principe que on
apprend en s'amusant gas uk open your
eyes on a l'impression qu'ils se rendent
pas compte que
c'est un apprentissage pour eux c'est
juste des jeux et puis après il réalise
qu'en fait ça peut être utile
c'est une association qui existe depuis
plus de 45 ans qui a été créé par une
maman qui voulait faire apprendre
l'anglais à ses enfants
plus tôt ils apprennent mieux il se
forme l'oreille géré par montigny faune
english l'association existe depuis 40
ans à montigny le bretonneux chaque
année 90 enfants apprennent à
communiquer dans la langue de
shakespeare
les cours reprendront à la rentrée
ghodsi des fesses
ok mais 17 millions d'euros montant
global estimé des travaux pour
sauvegarder le potager du roi à
versailles le site vient de transmettre
son plan global de restauration et de
valorisation
un dossier de mécénat déposée auprès de
la fondation américaine world monuments
fund créée sous louis xiv classé
monument historique le potager du roi a
besoin de fonds pour rénover ses mur
d'enclos notamment 15% sont aujourd'hui
dans un état préoccupant
un chantier nécessaires en vue de ce
rendez-vous dans un an
le lieu accueillera la première édition
de la biennale internationale de l'
architecture de l'urbanisme et du
paysage
le sport on prend la direction du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
chesnaie open de france débute demain
jeudi avec un plateau très relevé elle
et 40000 spectateurs attendus pourront
notamment voir en action le numéro deux
mondial l'américain justin thomas est le
numéro 1 français alexander levy
reportage un jour du coup d'envoi de la
compétition avec mickaël landreau
les drapeaux sont hissés à les greens
coupé au millimètre et les joueurs sont
arrivés tout est prêt pour accueillir ce
jeudi 28 joie la 102e édition de l'open
de france sur le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines pour l'omd 4 jours
les joueurs ont juste à jouer jouez bien
le parcours est super dont eux ils ont
des surfaces de jeu fantastique
maintenant on attend un beau vainqueur
dimanche soir le futur vainqueur
pourrait se nommer justin thomass le
numéro 2 mondial sera considéré comme le
favori de l'épreuve pour sa première sur
le tournoi l'américain veut gagner pour
préparer la future ryder cup 2018 qui se
tiendra sur le même parc
décision qui pourrait ravir le capitaine
de l'équipe américaine jim furyk
il a compris qu'il y avait des choses à
mettre en place des stratégies à faire
pour préparer notre corps et notre jeu à
la saison évidemment la ryder cup pour
moi mais il y à d'autres tournois
jusqu'à la ryder cup
j'ai essayé de faire le meilleur
planning pour mapa du côté des français
le numéro 1 alexander levy 27 ans va
tenter de décrocher sa qualification
pour la ryder cup en remportant son
premier open de france
pour mettre toutes ses chances de son
côté le varois a analysé le parcours
on a passé six heures sur le parcours a
vraiment essayé de le planifier au mieux
de bêtes plein de stratégie et pouvoir
bien m'entraîner à a joué intelligemment
ce parcours alexander levy devra
répondre présent dès ce jeudi 28 juin à
8 heures il lancera les hostilités sur
cet open de france 2010 8 à justin
thomas c'est le vainqueur de l'an passé
est au mifi twitter elle est et sera
animée à la maison à triolet aragon le
lieu propose deux ateliers vacances pour
les 4 12 ans ça se passe ça les 11
juillet 29 août pour en parler avec moi
un nouvel invité pierre colas mon soir
ça vous êtes chargé de communication à
la maison à triolet aragon alors on va
parler de l'été animé dans un instant
d'abord pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas
ce lieu qui est donc situé à
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines et non pas 50
ans ni mais comme je le disais tout à
l'heure à il est situé donc dans un au
coeur d'un parc de 5 hectares et ce à un
endroit qui a été une source
d'inspiration pour deux auteurs elsa
triolet triolet pardon et louis aragon
oui c'était ce genre de fontaine dans
laquelle on revient tout le temps pour
les deux écrivains ce qu'ils avaient
acheté cette maison dans les années 50
et qui revenait là justement pour écrire
leur livre ils y ont passé énormément de
temps ils sont beaucoup parlé de ce lieu
un wagon a écrit beaucoup de poèmes
aussi sur ses sur les pas sur le parquet
sur les sur les petits chemins dans
lesquelles il se baladait depuis le lieu
il n'a pas vraiment changé
puisque maintenant il a été donné à la
nation française et il est géré et il
est ouvert au public toute l'année
et justement on essaie de le faire vivre
à travers des activités des
manifestations comme cet été il y en
aura un certain nombre et sera un bel
été ensoleillé on va développer ça dans
un instant justement cette maison à
trois vocations quelle qu'elles sont
elles ces vocations
donc si volonté mémoire se souvenir des
écrivains se souvenir de leurs modèles
de leur héritage littéraire comme on
visite le râleur leur maison c'est aussi
à une volonté de recherche avec toute la
bibliothèque qu'on a on peut comme ça
explorer les fonds et ça sert encore aux
chercheurs qui viennent qui viennent
fouiner dans la gueule dans les greniers
et enfin 7 c'est une volonté de toujours
faire un lien entre les artistes et de
public et que grâce aux expositions
qu'on organise tout au tout le tout au
long de l'année ont eux on puisse rang
on puisse faire justement cette
rencontre donc vous accusez sur place du
public tout au long de l'année c'est ça
oui on accueille du public aussi bien
public individuel des familles des
nostalgiques de deschamps deschamps a
des chansons de ferrat ou de féret est
aussi bien des classes des groupes qui
viennent justement vous parlez de classe
il ya un projet qui se développe en ce
moment dans le cadre de ces mon
patrimoine qui est une opération
nationale portée par le ministère de la
culture
vous avez développé un projet street art
avec les élèves de l'école lenôtre de
son champ c'est ça exactement ça c'est
un petit peu particulier en profitent de
la période des vacances mais pour le blé
pour les étudiants qui vont pas
s'arrêter là et il vient justement
on a réfléchi à la manière dont ils
pourraient s'approprier ce lieu
littéraire est aussi c'était aussi très
facile en passant par le street art
de trouver une porte d'entrée et à
travers ça eh bien ils vont ils vont
selon pouvoir expérimenter en même temps
qu'ils vont apprendre l on avait
énormément d'artistes street art qui
était déjà passé on avait fait des
expositions se faire une opinion et
ranaz sur jef aérosol sur le valais
actuellement c'est l'exposition qu'on a
en ce moment et là justement il y aura
une fresque à la clé qui sera réalisé
par les par les étudiants mais ça se
fera donc à travers tout un chemin qui
sera proposée est donc ce sera un
patrimoine à la fois historique dans la
maison et en même temps un patrimoine
très contemporain alors vous l'avez dit
l'été sera animée à la maison à triolet
aragon déjà dès ce dimanche 1er juillet
à 14h vous associer à la ville de
saint-arnoult-en-yvelines pour proposer
jardins en fête une après-midi bucolique
et poétique et politique je vais y
arriver
c'est très difficile aujourd'hui alors
quels sont les objectifs de cet
événement jardins en fête c'est en fait
je veux dire que c'est un moment
extrêmement touchant pour nous ce que
vous avez savent toujours justement à la
fin d'une année scolaire
et c'est un moment où on va vraiment
mélanger les arts et on aura donc des
arts de rue avec un piano manège qui
sera installé mais on aura aussi une
pièce de théâtre qui nous sont si durs
libre sensibilisera à l'écologie on aura
aussi un atelier qui nous fera faire des
instruments de musique aussi et puis en
même temps des associations locales qui
nous proposerons aussi bien du dessin
que la photographie de la vannerie
on aura des déambulations scientifique
dans le par pour explorer l'infiniment
petit d'accord on aura
on aura encore des balades en barques ou
finalement ce qu'il faut retenir
williams multitude d'animations
d'ateliers c'est qu'il ya une variété
vous dites des spectacles des
démonstrations des visites également
voilà c'est très varié ce programme pour
être pour jardins en fête vous venez
participer autant autant vous allez être
impliqué dans les ateliers c'est aussi
des associations locales qui participent
à ce programme et qu'ils font réussir
chaque année et je rappelle que jardins
en fête c'est ce dimanche à partir de 14
heures et l'entrée est libre enfin j'en
parlais en début d'interview
cet été seront proposés à la maison elsa
triolet deux ateliers vacances pour les
4 12 ans ça se passe les 11 juillet et
29 août
quel est le principe de ces ateliers le
principe des ateliers c'est de toujours
correspondre un petit peu à nos
actualités et là notre actualitté c'est
une exposition sur le valais donc un
dessinateur qui qui qui dessinent
principalement dans les rues sur les
murs des villes et il dessine en général
des personnages qui ont l'air toujours
en mouvement et là ça nous amène des
données une envie de te d'illustrer ce
mouvement au travers des 10 et des
petits jouets de proto cinéma et vieux
autres up les thaumatrope les l'évier
l'évier et les choses les petits et
petits les petits objets qu'on fait
tourner et puis ça fait une petite
illusion d'optique et là dedans bas donc
des quatre ans on pourra on pourra en
fabriquer soi-même et comment fait-on
pour y participer
on doit inscrire ses enfants si on
souhaite que le parti ça ça oui ça c'est
sur inscription d'accord puisque on a un
public qui est fidèle et kiki qui a
envie de revenir à chaque fois et donc
il faut il faut donc téléphoné pour pour
donner son nom avant le avant l'atelier
encore trouvé le numéro de téléphone sur
le titre le site internet qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran et retrouvez aussi
toutes les informations dont on a parlé
dans cet entretien merci pierre colas
est d'avoir été avec nous ou bien si
notre habitation je rappelle que vous
êtes chargé de communication à la maison
elsa triolet louis aragon et elle est
située à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines est
la recherche d'un monde meilleur c'est
le thème de la 7e édition du festival
les images vagabonde les spectateurs
peuvent voir ou revoir des films autour
du sujet plusieurs bibliothèques centres
de loisirs et cinéma d'ici
ligne et participent jusqu'au 13 juillet
et notamment le signer sept ans il
encourt nicolas landry et tutti nirhy
lanto avant-première des affamés à
elancourt au ciné cette c'est l'occasion
pour les spectateurs d'échanger avec la
réalisatrice du film
une rencontre organisée dans le cadre du
festival les images vagabonde
un événement à l'initiative de
l'association contre champ ça fait
partie de notre dynamique d'action
culturelle menée tout au long de l'année
on fait pas mal de choses et donc c'est
le moment de contrechamp mi juin et c
est un moment qui est maintenant pour
nous est inscrit dans notre calendrier
d'action culturelle on dire au programme
de ces quatre semaines des oeuvres
cultes mais aussi des nouveautés sur le
thème d'un monde meilleur à l'image des
affamés le film qui sort le 27 juin met
en avant une jeunesse en délicatesse
avec les études et les débuts sur le
monde du travail réalisé par les affres
de vannes il est incarnée entre autres
par l'actrice et chanteuse luan et
meurent à aujourd'hui je bouge c'est à
ce moment là que j'ai compris et je ne
sais pas juste une catégorie d'âge c'est
une place sociale
nous devons tout sans rien nous donner
en échange je voulais représenter je
voulais que ce soit des gens qui soient
différents les uns des autres qui se
retrouve de part leur génération et de
par leur âge mais qui viennent
de milieux différents qui est des
couleurs de peau différentes qui est des
aspirations différentes aussi est
effectivement dans le film on a un
banquier une agence immobilière
un dj un journaliste voilà il ya toute
forme de deux quêtes le cinéma cède
participe pour la deuxième fois au
festival
outre les affamés plusieurs films sont
proposés de la science fiction au
documentaire en passant par l'animation
les visiteurs auront libre cours pour ce
faire une ou plusieurs toiles clap de
fin le 13 juillet prochain entre voir
l'invisible cela peut paraître compliqué
c'est ce que propose en tout cas la
commanderie des templiers avec une
exposition ça se passe donc à elle en
cours depuis le 11 avril vous pouvez
vous familiariser avec la science de
façon ludique comme avec cette séance de
light painting les visiteurs ont pu
s'essayer à des expériences avec la
lumière et la photo nicolas landry et
tous qui nirhy lanto c'est bon c'est
fini
un appareil photo des lampes de couleurs
ces ateliers light painting à elancourt
une activité dans le cadre de
l'exposition entre voir l'invisible en
bleu en verre ou en rouge on écrit et on
dessine avec la lumière
c'est une technique de photos qui permet
de saisir le mouvement de le mouvement
de lumière notamment avec des petites
lampes torches et ensuite d'autres
systèmes avec des led mais voilà donc de
saisir le mouvement lumineux avec un
appareil photo
ça permet de créer des formes des objets
comme emplie imprimé dans l'air on va
dire font un appareil photo qui est
qu'un temps d'obturation qui est capable
donc de prendre une photo sur une
période assez longue
outre l'aspect ludique le light painting
simplifie la science l'activité mais en
pratique optique infiniment petit ou
encore trajet de la lumière des notions
complexes que les visiteurs test
lumières et appareils photos à l'appui
le light painting semble convaincre les
visiteurs
j'ai essayé d'écrire mon prénom j'ai
fait un coeur avec ma mère et j'ai fait
les roues d'un vélo c'était trop bien je
pensais pas que ça existait c'était
super les enfants ont adoré c'était très
ludique on a pu participer nous aussi à
l'atelier de light painting et voilà je
pense qu'on repart avec des bonnes idées
pour faire des ateliers avec les enfants
l'exposition entrevoir l'invisible se
tient à la commanderie des templiers
elle se termine le 1er juillet et dans
un instant ne manquait pas un nouveau
7,8 culture présentée par mélanie poquet
assez la fin de ce journal les
reportages sont à revoir sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile td
78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]